it's an epidemic that's coming to us
it's this wave a pulse of of the virus
as it's spreading from person to person
and growing exponentially and the reason
that this is very important is that
let's say for the sake of argument a
hundred thousand Americans are going to
die of this condition in the next year
it makes all the difference in the world
whether those hundred thousand died over
the course of the next year or whether
all hundred thousand died in the next
month if they die in the next month are
gonna overwhelm our health care system
and many more Americans will die than
would have died if we allowed our health
care system and our supply chain to work
[Music]
joining me today is a sociologist and
physician known for his research on
social networks and on the
socio-economic bio social and
evolutionary determinants of behavior
health and longevity Nick Christakis
welcome back to the Rubin report thank
you for having me Dave
I'm glad to have you back wish we could
be doing this live but obviously we're
practicing a little social distancing
right now with everything going on with
Corona I've been trying to find a wide
array of people to talk to you put out
what I thought was a really fantastic
Twitter thread I rarely send people to
Twitter but you put out a great Twitter
thread that covered this through all of
the disciplines that I just read there
in your bio which are quite extensive so
let's just start one at a time the the
two things that people have heard the
most about at the moment
social distancing and flattening the
curve can you just explain both and why
they're important right now yeah so the
virus takes advantage of the fact that
we are social animals that we assemble
in groups that we have friends that we
touch each other and hug each other and
now and it uses those connections that
we assemble ourselves into these
networks it uses those connections as a
highway to travel through our species
and so the challenge for us right now is
how to interrupt that highway how to
break the paths that the virus uses to
travel from person to person to person
to person
the reason that's important is that this
flattening the curve idea so so we're
gonna engage in social distancing we're
gonna stop interacting with each other
we're gonna keep physically apart from
each other that's the most important
thing in fact I've been advocating for a
shift in terminology to physical
distancing from social distancing in
other words we we can still interact
socially but from a distance when you
and I are doing now okay and uh and so
we want physical distance e we want to
iron ease we want to like you know bond
together at the same time as we are sort
of separating from each other in terms
physically anyway the reason we're
engaging in that physical distancing is
to cut the path through the network and
the reason we're doing that is to
flatten the curve what does that mean
well it's an epidemic that's coming to
us it's this wave a pulse of of the
virus as it's spreading from person to
person and growing exponentially and the
reason that this is very important is
that let's say for the sake of argument
a hundred thousand Americans are going
to die of this condition in the next
year it makes all the difference in the
world whether those hundred thousand
died over the course of the next year or
whether all hundred thousand died in the
next month if they die in the next month
they're gonna overwhelm our healthcare
system and many more Americans will die
than would have died if we allowed our
health care system and our supply chain
to work so we want to flatten the curve
we've got this peak of a curve where
everyone you know the epidemic is coming
at us and it's gonna hit lots of people
at the same time we want to stop it from
doing that and flatten the curve and
push it out into the future and when we
do that we achieve a number of
objectives first of all at any given
point fewer people are sick so our
health care system can take care of them
many more might live as a result of that
second we we push some of the cases out
into the future so that maybe some of
the people that get sick eventually will
get sick at a time when we've invented a
vaccine or we know better how to treat
the people so we also gain that benefit
by flattening the curve and as I said
not only do we decompress our healthcare
system not only do we push people into
the future when we might be better able
to
for them but we reduce mortality as well
so maybe instead of a hundred thousand
dying maybe ninety thousand died if we
push it forward so that's why we're
social distancing and that's what
flattening the curve means Hebburn were
obviously in some unchartered territory
with coronavirus and our plan here is to
help you make as much sense of the
situation and a non alarmist fashion as
possible if you're looking for reliable
information from experts on the front
lines of the pandemic check out our
coronavirus playlist which will keep
adding updates - right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe